this is screen junkies movie fights
brought to you by nature box now your
host Andy
signor Hello everybody welcome to
another episode of movie fights and I
know I hype a lot of shows but holy crap
today is going to be a doozy I don't
know how I'm going to do it but I'm
going to try my best we've got some
amazing questions but it's even more fun
because it's a blind fight and it's
three of our best fighters open up to
the wide look who it is Mr Hal Rudnick
most people might not know this Hal I
don't know if they know this but you
have the most wins underneath the champ
wow I don't like how you phrase
that um there was a certain sexual
connotation that I took away from that
but in today's blind movie fight I hope
to be Matt Murdoch yeah well you're in a
lot just for people know Hal hasn't been
on as often as we like cuz Hal's busy
doing some exciting work we're excited
oh can I mention that go ahead sure I'm
writing on a Disney Channel Disney XD
show called walk the prank
and I'm enjoying the hell out of it it's
fun it's hard we get very limited time
with how cuz he's a busy guy 9 to so he
makes jugy show still happen but it's
honor to have you back on the show some
fun the fans have miss you this is going
to be a good one all right next to him
you guys have have wanted to see him
take on the champ because he is
basically a killer in the speed round Mr
Coy jandrew welcome coy so excited it's
good to be here I uh feel honored to be
amongst these two gentlemen it's GNA be
a good fight be fun I'm prepared and
last but not least he is the champ
the world reigning movie fights Champion
you've defended that honor so many times
more times than I can count Mr Dan Merl
hi now Dan I have to ask is this a belt
mat or just just an exposition you know
we talked and I and I said it's been a
long time since I was able to just kind
of fight for fun just fight to have a
good time so I want I just want to fight
for fun I want to have a good time back
to the old Dan back to the old Dan fting
forging are good all right and if one of
these people beats you then you might
need to consider if one I think that
it's pretty crystal clear that if I do
not win whomever is the Victor today
would have a pretty clear shot as the uh
as a as a serious Contender for the belt
so like preliminary I like it it's like
a the Nascar race we're all trying to
get our times yes this is going to be
intense cuz I I'm telling you these
three are three of our best it's going
to be very intense and they're going to
be fighting some amazing things such as
uh worst dairo movie uh best animal
sidekick in a Disney movie worst comic
book movie and best scorey movie so
these are some legit topics and what so
fun is it's a blind fight you guys are
going to have to go off basically on
what you you get cuz we're going to be
random draws how this worked uh so if
they pick the one you wanted you're
going to have to Pivot and pick another
one so are you guys ready for this my
wheels are
turning before we start I guess I have
to introduce this guy on the on the fan
cam uh Joe star Hey Joe hey Andy it's a
Dog Day Afternoon here on movie fights
brother and I tell you there is no puppy
love lost on these competitors fans on
Twitter # movie fights live on want to
know if Hal and Koy are going to be more
bite than bark and if Old Dan's got any
new
tricks Joe this episode is sponsored by
the
ASPCA why did I miss something why are
you doing why the pun oh there's nothing
I love Joe Joe you love me right we're
good right yeah we're fine we're good
there's no drama between Jo and happy
holidays Joe all right Joe you're going
to do your best over there to fact check
things right keep compl partial and down
the middle
Andy I'm
there was drama last week we oh Goa yeah
yeah yeah Goa got like wrestling oh yeah
yeah yeah oh Stone facing oh yeah should
I take off my shirt and turn heel anyway
let me go back to it yeah Joe's really
delightful and I love Joe oh of course
Joe you
suck okay uh but here's how this is
going to work guys you know how this
game is played I want to Hype some
things at the end of this show I'm going
to Hype some huge movie fights coming up
that I don't know you guys are not going
to want to miss including the fan fights
you guys can still submit right now when
that's going to happen but if you
haven't there you go sj. plusus famam if
you think you can come here under the
lights and fight you got a few more days
or a week I think left whatever it is
submit ASAP your video two-minute video
and you could join us to Fan fights
we're going to f fly a bunch of fans out
here to try and do this it's going to be
blast are we going to put them up in
five star hotels I don't know about a
five star they will be in a good about
say safe good hotel they will have stars
they will have stars points St guarantee
uh plus some other epic fights that I
will announce at the end remind me to
announce I like to tease uh so you'll
stay tuned that some big fights uh
coming up that you guys will not want to
miss live here on uh scenes.com or on
YouTube all right before we start I do
have to thank today's sponsor so happy
to have them back ladies and gentlemen
it's Nature Box Joe has the box over
there and I love nature box uh because
they make snacks that actually taste
great and are better for you they're
created with high quality ingredients
and they're free from artificial colors
flavors sweeteners so you can feel great
about snacking and Joe over there has
some options some some snacks uh that
are in there there's over a 100 snacks
to choose from like age Chen or lenol
loops and mini Belgian waffles what else
is in there Joe well no more Belgian
waffles cuz I ate them in the time it
took you to say that sentence we've got
aago and cheddar cheese crisps which are
dope we've got hickory smoked turkey
jerky oh I do want that also real dope
this is all I actually want to try all
that and you guys you could try all this
to get it delivered right to your door
uh subscribers can order as much as you
want as of as you want with no minimum
purchase required and you can cancel at
any time so go to
naturebox.com junkies and sign up uh is
there I guess there's no offer code just
do that I don't have one on my script I
assume just go to
naturebox.com screenjunkies and tell
them that we sent you and try a nature
box and I I actually love nature box
I've done it it's oh sure I mean um
guilt-free snacking sign me up yeah it's
good to get like all sent to you and
fresh fun stuff so thank you Nature Box
please go support them uh thank you Joe
for showing off the food you did it well
thanks I will give you that compliment
thanks boss all right let's do this come
on let's get nuts I want to fight you
you want to fight let him fight fight
stop this fight
I I can do this all
day all right guys here we
go round one we drew straws this is how
it happened so that's the order we're
going to go with today and then it's
going to take turns every time so that's
how it's going to work 1 2 3 1 two three
okay so how you're up first and you get
to do the first blind fight and it's a
big one what is the worst Robert dairo
performance Hal you get to go first oh
my okay all right remind everyone at
home this is a blind fight so they have
not been able to prepare and they don't
know what the other ones are going to
pick go ahead H okay so uh Robert Deno
has an incredible IMDb obviously but
he's made some stinkers and there are
many uh substandard Robert dairo films
and a few performances now in thinking
of this the question said performance it
did say performance so I'm going to put
aside some of the bad Roberton Nero
films and go to what I believe is his
worst performance also a terrible film
and that would be the Adventures of
Rocky and bowling okay The Adventures of
Rocky and Bullwinkle he made choices as
an actor that made the hair stand up on
my neck and made me want to just scratch
the skin off of my own face leaving a
red mask of blood I was so
infuriated watching his comedic overthe
toop choices um it was a very car uh
carish cartoony poorly chosen derivative
villain that he played all of his
choices it was like he took pieces of
like huh what's the standard bad guy in
a cartoon sound like and then in
addition he jumped the shark with that
role he had already been doing other
roles that brought his career down
several notches several pegs but for him
to parody himself with you talking to me
that was the stake in the heart
of his
integrity if that doesn't pull the rug
out from under him performance-wise more
than anything else I don't know what is
all right Coy let's go to you what do
you think is the worst dairo performance
so mine is very recent uh it was the
first movie I've seen in a long time
that starred any actor of his Acclaim
that made me physically uncomfortable
and that is the Zack Efron magnumopus
dirty Grandpa now dirty grandpa is not
only offensive to the demographic it's
trying to appease it's offensive to
everyone involved with that film because
you have Efron who's been working very
hard to get credible so I would love to
see him work with daero but then daero
does a performance that feels like
you're watching your grandpa who doesn't
have any actor acting experience wander
into frame and just say things it wasn't
acting it wasn't performing it was a man
who like just needed the paycheck so bad
he said whatever perverse things were
thrown at him it was uncomfortable on
levels that made you feel like you were
watching American Pie with your grandma
because you were experiencing an elderly
person Tred to experience youth culture
so it was like tears of why is this
happening I'm uncomfortable I know
you're uncomfortable is this what it's
like to sell out you're Robert to Nero
why are any of us here nobody had any
Victory there you couldn't pay me to
talk to dairo about that performance mus
watch that movie again it was the most
agonizing experience and I never thought
I would not want to see dick jokes come
out of Dao's mouth but now that I've
seen it it's a fate worse than death
doesn't he like have sex with Aubrey
Plaza and somehow that's not pleasant
you expect that to be a good time it is
Dan you guys are no fun uh here's my
choice uh and this was one it came from
the 9s there was a bit of a horror
Resurgence in the 90s and this was a
risk that Robert Jiro took that I don't
think paid off in the least it is his
role as Frankenstein's monster and Mary
Shell's Frankenstein with Kenneth Brena
as the mad scientist uh Frank Dr
Frankenstein um I get why I wanted to do
this I guess cuz Gary Oldman played
Dracula and everyone was like oo Oldman
was great as Dracula so he was like okay
I'll play Frankenstein but that's the
problem is that's how he played
Frankenstein he's got the stitches and
everything but every time they're like
oh look at him like everyone's got like
the Victorian things the Frankenstein's
monster and he's like yeah don't take a
thing like he's playing Robert dairo is
like you know I'm doing this like he's
like he's like doing a parody of Igor
from the original Universal monsters
like we belong dud it's just it is so
laughable and so over the toop and just
so so not in sync with the rest of that
movie like at least Dracula had that
really weird Francis Ford Copa sense of
just going over the top and K Reeves is
there for some reason and it made sense
why Gary Oldman was acting like a crazy
person but dairo is there he's trying to
be a monster but he's still just kind of
dairo he could have gone way over the
top but instead he just kind of went for
like you know Robert dairo and it did
not work at all it was a bad choice it
was a poor performance and in a movie
called Frankenstein if Frankenstein
doesn't work as the monster you're in
trouble all right guys well I will
contend that Frankenstein is actually
the doctor uh so it is Frankenstein's
monster so a movie called Frankenstein
you might think about uh the doctor also
um he made an over-the-top choice in the
Adventures of Rocky and Bullwinkle and
it was so much more unnerving and skin
crawling than that performance that
performance was lukewarm this
performance was just I am getting gutted
over and over again let me can I ask you
something you said it was comedic over
the top and cartoony and he's playing
the standard bad guy from a cartoon he
is playing the standard bad guy from a
cartoon there's literally a cartoon
moose and squirrel next to him in the
movie he did it in such a way where it
was so unwatchable it was like nails on
a chalkboard for 90 minutes to 2 hours
long it you think he was going to do in
the movie there's no version of Rocky
buo diniro that would be anything else
than that possibly do something where he
could immerse himself and play a
wonderfully fun villain rather than it
was like RI he had the monagle he was
having a good time like if you put that
role if you gave that role to say Allan
cuming Allan cuming or um let's say um a
young like a young Michael Kane someone
who could pull off or a Heath Ledger or
or someone who I feel like both of these
they he was having a good time he got to
play Frankenstein he got to play in my
movie he not only didn't have a good
time no one had a good time it felt like
Ziro literally got lost ended up on set
with Zack Efron and then just said dick
a lot like nobody had a good experience
at least there he got to like that was a
passion Pro for him this was a passion
Pro for him how did this happen how did
this performance get so off guard that
he just like wanted maybe he wanted to
show up and say dick and balls a bunch
of times hey he just did the intern he
just had a comedy Resurgence the intern
was just before that we learned he could
do comedy he'd had his little fuers
experience there was no reason for this
performance to be so bad cuz we saw that
he could do it that was an experiment I
would mention little fuers in uh
as an example of
know but the monster and and I mean the
monster is Bor carof did great like you
can really bring some great acting
gravitas to that role and the fact that
he didn't do that at all and just kind
of his his way through that movie it's
just I just he's on a completely
different level from anyone else in that
movie and I feel like dirty Grandpa he
didn't turn down it is unlike seen him's
main point was that the the material was
beneath him it wasn't about the
performance Dan's Dan's main point was
that he was kind of n he was kind of uh
it was half monster half dairo this
performance this performance was a
choice and it practically ruined the
movie uh and on top of that he gave that
devastating line of are you talking to
me which causes you to take pause this
performance caused you to take pause and
look back on this whole man's career and
ask yourself does it add up am I buying
into Fool's Gold here that was the line
in this performance he delivered the
moment that soured everyone on Roberton
you're s Everyone
onert no actually it was the fan that uh
I think caused us to take pause a little
bit Rocky gold though like I remember
hearing about about that movie and the
thing that I heard was about that scene
and it's like oh Robert dairo is playing
with his image he's doing an OM like
he's he's having fun with his career and
a lot of actors do that and again like
the the performance it is a cartoon
movie this is a movie that he wanted to
makeer he shephered that movie through
production for years he wanted to do
Rocky and Bullwinkle and he had a lot he
had a really good time playing that
build wonderful that's that's all
wonderful but that doesn't change the
fact that no his his cartoon villain
what like he he's inept he cannot play
that I would not cast Robert diero I
would cast him to play something I would
not cast him as a voice actor I get all
all these are bad let's agree to that so
last closing points here why why is the
why are the two
worse not as bad I mean I I feel like
the tone of the performance in both of
your films was appropriate for the film
I'm not talking about my credibility of
the script or what have you the
performance in in mind could have made
Robert dairo more of a wide-range actor
the performance in yours fit the tone
the performance in mine was cringeworthy
to a level that it distracted from the
whole movie and the movie had no chance
of recovering itself he played a cartoon
in a cartoon villain he played
Frankenstein and Frankenstein this movie
just made you feel like your grandpa was
in the movie with you just making you
uncomfortable in front of your
girlfriend and that's not a performance
that's not knowing how to act and that
is a bad performance D I think that mine
is the worst because it really severely
handicapped the film you had a role that
required some good acting it did not get
his best it was just Robert dairo under
some makeup making the Robert dairo face
and not really bringing any acting to it
I think how didn't like the tone of the
movie that Robert dairo was in I think
Koy didn't like the material of the
movie and thought was beneath Robert
dairo doing it but I think my
performance was the worst because it
completely crippled the entire film
how ky's Choice uh he's saying it it was
cringeworthy cuz he was like it was like
you were there with uh your grandfather
that sounds like that was an effective
thing is supposed to be a dirty weird
Grandpa that you wouldn't want to be a
part of mission accomplished uh and like
your main argument was that the material
was beneath him and uh to Dan's Point uh
H how's how's a monster supposed to talk
okay he did it half dairo half monster
it was his dairo monster whatever that
he made a choice here this was the most
misguided it was Nails on a chalkboard
yes you're supposed to be big and yes he
shephered it through that should have
helped him instead it hurt him and
someone I think he's a victim of no one
told him no and uh he just went above
and beyond excruciating cringeworthy
acting it it's like he's like Dr
Evil yeah it was terrible it was so
terrible and
derivative and he paried himself and
lost okay any other fighing closing
thoughts um I I have no problem let's
see who you picked
I'm waiting for the belt there we go oh
hey Bel all right there
we there it was all right Str
taffic all right Joe star over there on
the on the boards uh Twitter's got some
thoughts uh Nolan Dean says little fuers
din did not give a single [__] a Fu a
Fu uh uh even though I don't agree with
anything you say you're still a funny
guy Andy signore K Tigers says I'm
pretty sure we all know it's nightfall
it was so bad it's not even listed on
his he was great at nightfalls David
Bowman says whatever his character's
name is star was in Stardust and I can't
disagree with you more David Bowman that
is a great performance he was he was a
fancy fun pirate in Stardust there's not
a lot of facts Andy to you know it's
it's an opinion round but I I went to
the uh to the opinions of a of one of
the most famous movie opinion guys there
is Robert Ebert who had this to say
about rer
brother oh my bad
oh my god well hold on hold the horses
what did Robert Ebert say you know
what's weird I copi and pasted that that
was really weird anyway
rer thanks JT yeah I had JT install a
boo sound just cuz I knew you would need
a show with that guy Jake
cisc I love Jake Jake CIS say I love his
oh man all right but tell us more about
Robert Eber well Robert uh says this uh
I admired the scenes with dairo so much
uh what are we talking about uh Mary
Shell's Frankenstein I admired the
scenes with Robert dairo so much I'm
attempted to give Mary Shel Frankenstein
a favorable verdict 2.5 out of three
stars uh with out of four stars he
didn't riew four they gave three this is
Robert eberts it Robert E three stars
did he review uh the other two
performances no could have reviewed dty
Grandpa uh uh the website might have we
don't know
Robert
might be his own plan n from outer space
a bomb uh and Bullwinkle yes uh adored
it Robert eutely Ador it good old Robert
absolutely Ador it all right are you
trolling live on air just they loved you
last week Joe they're not going to love
you this it's okay no I'm kidding we all
love you Robert Ebert the dog reviewer
the dog reviewer online two paws up
first our veterans Joe now Roger Eber
can we get Spencer in here on the k that
uh that movie really made my Tail
Wag uh all right uh based on the
arguments oh and you have a Twitter did
we do a Twitter poll yeah okay hold on
sorry no we didn't use Twitter we used
uh twatter we used TW oh twatter poll
okay we have the twatter poll great
Jesus um based on the arguments it was
actually really neck and neck you guys
are the best so some of the best so that
makes sense but I I was really I was
listening to your final closing and I
was swayed by Hal I mean when you sort
of turned Coy's argument against him and
said well that actually kind of makes it
effective and that he's playing a
monster it is what it is uh I got to
give Hal the ultimate point so how
you're first on the
board uh What did the what did the
twatter pole say uh twatter pole
completely disrespected veteran fighter
Dan Merl and went with Coy's pick of
dirty grandpa with 47% because it came
out
last yours was in the '90s no one
watching was alive very true uh Rocky
Bullwinkle 34 okay uh was that your
first choice Dan was what yeah we'll
find out after you'll never know
after you brought up nightfalls a little
I'm going to tease guys there's so many
fun movie moments we've done over the
past 100 episodes wouldn't it be cool if
we counted down the top 50 ever W where
would nightfalls fall in that rank we
will tell you more at the end of this
episode stay tuned o nice
tease all right round
two this one comes uh what well someone
on Twitter has suggested it sorry we
didn't pull your
name uh but this is an epic one I I
don't know how I'm going to judge this
one Joe we will need to put our our our
our our in thing on the side because I
will need your help potentially here uh
this is an ultimate question what is the
best Martin Scorsese
movie uh there's a lot though so coy
you're up first you get to pick
first now this is going to seem
misguided and I understand that the
internet will probably very upset that I
chose something that you know what I'm
just going to say The Departed I feel
like is the best Martin scores movie
because it is one of the most
rewatchable movies ever not just by
scores by anyone it reshaped how people
perceived Boston before The Departed it
was there was movies that took place in
New York where they were sometimes in
Boston or there was Goodwill Hunting The
Departed made an entire sub genre of
Boston crime film because of how good
Square SES departed was it had amazing
performances by each and every member of
the cast The supporting actors were just
as good as the lead actors the lead
actors were just as good as the eding
editing the writing everything about it
it won four Oscars in major categories
it won writing it won best picture it
won best directing and it won best
editing the movie is so tight it is so
perfect it is so rewatchable that you
get a full range of emotions where
you're laughing at Alec Bowman's crazy
performance you're endeared by Mark
Wahlberg which we had not been to that
point like Mark Wahlberg completely
changed the game with that film you
don't know whether you love Matt Damon
or leardo DiCaprio it's got Matt Damon
playing a villain and Leo playing a good
guy both against type but also both
switching back and forth because they're
both undercover in other ways you've got
multifaced performances by two of the
best actors of Our Generations at their
Prime Leo killing it in every SE heon in
Matt Damon you don't know who to hate in
that film until the very end and it also
has one of the best endings ever wherein
everyone gets offed and you don't know
how to feel about it that movie is
visceral it's impacting it's effective
it's rewatchable it's got an amazing
soundtrack and it is the best use of
scorsese's ability to make you care
about crime and that's what he does best
Dan I mean I could I could give you four
different answers and argue them just as
passionately but I have to go with the
one that jumped into my head as soon as
you said what's the best SC disy movie
and that's Raging Bull I think that
Raging Bull is one of the greatest
portraits of humanity of a person of the
weakness and how weakness inside of you
can just eat away at you and how you can
have everything that you need in the
world as far as possessions as far as
everything else goes and how if you
don't have that thing within yourself
that allows you to be happy with who you
are that it will just Eat You Alive from
inside we just talked about the worst
Roberts Z Nero performances this was
perhaps his best performance as Jake
lamada I think that raging bll is such a
brilliant movie that it almost
transcends being a sesi movie like
there's so many things like you can say
oh among sesi movies this is the best
and among sesi movies this one's the
best Raging is one of the great movies
of all time and what he did in
conjunction with the editing with the
camera work with the acting with the
sound the shooting in black and white
everything it is just a beautiful
haunting tragic amazing movie and I
think it's his best Hal what are you
going to pick the answer is Good Fellas
Good Fellas is the movie that defined so
many tropes for crime movies Mafia films
telling storytelling the ride and fall
and it's the most echoed and aped and
borrowed from of scorsi films and it's
the most impactful you want to talk
about performances across the board Ray
Leota Lorraine brco and Robert dairo
among others so many of the tropes that
it created it set up there would be no
Sopranos without Good Fellas there would
be um so many of the movies we love
there would be no Boogie Nights without
Good Fellas Good Fellas tells a great
story it takes us on this rise and fall
of emotion and it may be I would call it
the most rewatchable film of all time
not only is it one of the it is scor's
best one of the most rewatchable it's a
clinic in editing shooting screenplay
and character development across the
board this film is just like
out all right guys fight it out hold on
I just want to help make sure all three
of these are great movies so you've all
sold me very well and why your films are
great but there's one when we going to
say best foresy movie Why over the other
two go ahead I think that these when I
want to watch a crime film Good Fellas
when I want to watch a portrait of a
singular actor or a singular character
absolutely ra I think that a parted is
as a movie the strongest film and I
think it's more it's also a crime movie
so you just said you rather watch Good
Fellas The Departed cuz I don't think I
don't think of departed as a crime movie
I think of it as a movie I literally
when I put in The Departed I'm like I'm
not going to sit back and watch a crime
film I'm watching a movie about people
right out of the gate right out of the
gate I got to say the um The Departed is
a is a very good movie it's substandard
compared to Good Fellas I'd even say
compared to casino I'd say it's in um
scor says he's top 10 but it's not his
best I don't think it is as rewatchable
I watched it on a plane last year and I
was slightly disappointed by it and you
said oh the characters are so
complicated we knew Damon was a piece of
[__] and DiCaprio had his heart in the
right place scar when you got to caring
about Damon you actually cared when you
cared about DiCaprio you actually cared
I never cared about any good and I and I
love but that's just one character Henry
Hill it good Fells is so much more
complex cuz scorsi created this
character Henry Hill who was a dirt bag
but you loved him it was such an amazing
antihero n for me Nicholson you hated
and loved simultaneously
that was based off what he little at the
end I feel like he phone in anything I
feel like every single actor in this was
them at their Prime and it's full of
A-list actors today these actors
starting here just ascended into the
glory they are now and without scor st's
perfect direct they already there they
were already there Alec Baldwin Mark
Walbert I think that the Departed iy is
a very rewatchable movie I think it had
an assist from infernal Affairs which
was already a great movie The Departed
is essentially a beat for beat remake of
that movie and I love The Departed but
for me I think that I can't put it as
high up in scores filmography because I
feel like he had a big boost there and
he had a lot to go on and a big head
start as far as Good Fellas goes I think
that that is one of a series of crime
films that scorsi does and he does them
well I think that it's similar to mean
streets it's similar to casino which I'm
in the minority here I like Casino a
little better personally than Goodfellas
they're both great films The Wolf of
Wall Street is similar to it he does
this kind of it's like kind of this
Montage form of of editing where they
have they have the popular music
underneath it it's a very similar style
and he does that style very well and
that style was created in Good Fellows
more or less but I mean streets had a
lot of style very similar to streets was
not as complex a film I watched that uh
I'm saying it was as complex a film but
I'm saying that it was a crime film it
had the popular music it had a lot of
this had Dao don't forget that Raging
Bull borrows so much of what dairo is
known for it's a New York story it's
peshi and dairo it has so much of what
you're crediting my film at all like any
other SC SEI film it is not a crime film
it is a story about dairo it does dairo
and peshi the actors but peshi first of
all absolutely brilliant in Raging Bull
as the brother he is that last scene
where he walks up to him in the parking
garage and he won't talk to him is
amazing but he's even better in Good
Fellas Good Fellas he's a portrait I'm
talk I'm not talking about what's the
best pesi movie here's what I'm say
talking if if you want to say for a
peshi performance I'm going for this is
the best scorsi film I'm going to tell
you why is not as rewatchable ring we're
not judging rewatchability here okay
Define Private Ryan is not as
rewatchable as The Departed that doesn't
criteria go into making a good movie
rewatchability fine performances good
editing good shooting great Direction
Thelma Shoemaker her his longtime editor
the way Goodfellas is woven together
it's like none other fil you want to
talk editing let's talk about the
editing in Raging Bull the editing of
those boxing
boxing has not been portrayed in film as
well I'll give I'll give that to you one
of the best boxing movies one of the
best boing moviesit movies boxing movies
of all time and it stands out from
everything else that Martin SC says he
did because Good Fellas as great as it
is I can put in there with mean streets
and the other crime films along with the
depart that's a
simplification raing b stands alone mov
unlike anything else that he made that's
what I think it is the best is cuz
coresi was going outside of his comfort
zone he was telling the story a
different kind of story than he was used
to telling okay how quickly and then
we're going to let Co other okay so I
agree raging you know Raging Bull of of
course I I'd be an idiot to say it's not
a very very good film but scor's talents
as a filmmaker were at the height of its
powers in Good Fellas he took everything
he' learned everything he known the way
it's woven together I defy you Dan to
tell me a sequence that beats that
walking into the Copa the walking into
that club scene one of the Great Moments
in cinema history on top of that it's a
steady cam shot people have been doing
steady cam shots for
years Dam I mean it's a steady cam shot
with a song underneath it I'm sorry Hal
it's it's not a sequence it's it's a
shot people they were running up the
stairs with Rockies in the 70s planned
choreographed that is Direction planning
of a shot doing a Bo match is Direction
too Hal and they've never done it better
than they did in in Raging Bull well
there are some sequences in Rocky that
I'll put uh I'll put up uh against some
of the stuff in Raging Bull but that
being said Good Fellas is is the
seasoned scores showing his stuff I feel
that when you speak of a director at the
height of their power and getting to the
point where they
combin either you I just said it yeah
yeah I'm I'm referencing your reference
when you talk of a director in the
height of their power when you talk of a
man who's at his aame who's got
everything he's learn put in one film it
is the power of caring about a single
actor in a sports film and the ability
to tell a crime s in one film I feel
like The Departed is the combination of
everything that led up to that point in
score sty and the academy agreed people
agreed it did the best because it wasn't
a sores film that felt like a sesy film
it was a movie that felt like a good
movie it didn't feel like a crime film
it didn't feel like raging bll it felt
like a near Perfect film that was beyond
the genre of Scorsese because each and
every actor in it had a full Arc each
and every character in it was fully
invested and everyone got to do their
best work all right I'm going to least
give you one last closing statement sure
this is it tell me why it's why the
other two aren't as good we're going to
start with you Hal since you've talked
the most go ahead and then I'll let you
two end up the The Departed is a good
film but it's in rewatching it it's a
little bit flawed it's a little bit slow
it's derivative as Dan said it's a
almost shot for shot for infer or scen
by scene for infernal Affairs also the
the Oscars he got for that were
borderline lifetime achievement awards
the same way Pacino won over Denzel
Washington I think it was 91 Denzel
Washington killed it in Malcolm X Mao 1%
of a woman it was a Lifetime Achievement
Award Dan uh that's a great nugget of a
film it's a gem but it is not the
Behemoth Masterpiece that is good Fellas
that combines uh the cinematography of I
think it's Michael b ball housee um
Thelma Shoemaker his editor all at their
very best the performances dairo hen uh
um Ray Leota Joe pesi that the
villainous Joe pesh
oh my God one of the most spine tingling
performances ever Lorraine bro an
amazing film Good Fellas the most
rewatchable film of all time scor says
he's best Dan's closing thoughts I think
that good Fellas benefits from him
riffing on what he'd done before in Mean
Streets I think the Good Fellas stood a
part because that was the first time we
seen him make that particular kind of
film I think he's made that kind of film
several times since with casino with the
Departed I'm not saying it's a bad film
I'm saying what sets Raging Bull apart
is that it is not only a fun watch and a
good depiction of of crime it is a
touching film it is a human story it
really gets deep inside the life of this
man this tortured man and it has
something to say it has something to say
about Humanity it has something to do
about the strength of being able to look
inside yourself and confront your own
personal demons it is a personal movie
it is a well-crafted movie it's more
than a great watch I think it is his
Masterpiece Coy you get to end
out when I look at a film I like to know
that I care about everyone involved when
I watch Raging Bull I care about one and
a half characters when I watch Good
Fellas I half care about many characters
when I watch The Departed I care about
both sides of a very specific coin I
care about the villain that's truly the
villain and Nicholson I care about two
guys that are practically brothers and
arms fighting opposite sides of the law
and I care about each and every cop in
that Bullpen so I feel like when I go to
see a film if I want to be invested in
every single character I'd rather watch
something that's like the dep parted
which isn't just a crime film which
isn't just a sports film which is the
best film SC ever made all right let
that one go a little long just cuz
intense Joe uh Twitter love that one and
uh we may have coined a new movie fights
phrase and I'm not going peshy for
peshy uh how about the fact that Hal
only said high of his powers once that
was some serious
restraint you're talking best and Good
Fellas I'm impressed you only got he's
an evolving fighter that Hal rednick
thank you uh Twitter uh has a couple of
other picks for favorite films Jeremy
Hastings says he loves paging bull with
Roger dairo I see what you do there
buddy sess Golem says games of New York
is a perfect movie nothing wrong with
that movie games of New York Gangs of
New York sorry I misspoke and uh uh we
can have a discussion about that we've
actually got a lot of uh love for Hugo
with some of our younger viewers that
was their introduction
to uh fun fact Larry Maki the guy who
shot uh Good Fellas says uh uh that uh
that track that U steady Camp shot
excuse me was blocked lit and filmed
before lunch in a half day wow wow that
is impressive damn all right based on
those arguments there was one person who
summed it up for me at one point I think
very well uh they queued up and kicked
out Koy when they sort of pointed out
that uh infernal Affairs really did set
up a lot of steps for him to be able to
go from uh and I just think it came down
between Dan and Hal but Dan between
getting that point out and a little bit
more against Hal I got to give Dan the
point for Raging
Bull good Joby man that hard pick if you
haven't seen either of these any of
these raging bll is my second choice uh
very good all right how did the how did
the poll go Joe uh raging bll actually
at 177% uh Good Fellas 48 and The
Departed at 35 wow there you go they
have you got old fil once again I take
the oldest
mie but a lot more good Fell's love than
I expected yeah right ni uh all right
here we go round three Dan you're up
first this time yeah and the question is
now if you noticed the trend we just did
worst we did best now we're back to
worst what is the worst prequel of all
time now there's a lot of prequels you
can pick it's not just the prequels as
some might say right uh so uh let's see
what you say
Dan uh I know it's not just the prequels
but I am going to go with one of the
prequels not the one that most people
would say though I I'm going to go with
the Star Wars Episode 2 attack of the
Clones and the reason that I'm going to
go with that is that I feel like as you
said Andy the prequels as there are now
know you just say the prequels and
people know what you're talking about
the prequels didn't become the prequels
with episode one The Phantom Menace it
was episode two attack of the Clones I
contend that actually sealed the fate of
the Star Wars prequels and the reason
why is that I still contend that for all
the bad things about The Phantom Menace
there were a number of good things that
that movie did a number of things that
got people still not really on their
heels so much until episode 2 that movie
undermined everything everything that
they were going for with these movies
that was the movie that cemented that
this was in real trouble that was the
movie that had the sand line that had
the line one of my favorite lines people
give that sand line so much crap but had
the line I'm haunted by the kiss that
you never should have given me that was
where the lame Love Story came from that
was where it really went wrong and
that's why I choose attack of the Clones
all right Hal you're
next the worst prequel of all time is
X-Men Origins The Wolverine it is
garbage it almost it almost sunk The
Wolverine uh as a character that we'd
want to see more often somehow they move
past that they're just like ah screw
we'll just keep making more movies and
they turn out to be much better but uh
it was a terrible movie the uh the
characters they cast around Wolverine
and the story they told around Wolverine
uh were very hard to watch and also a
departure from what we'd already like
seen from Wolverine in the X-Men movies
and also it uh had moments like uh Will
I Am appearing in uh an X-Men uh movie
and Ryan Reynolds as Deadpool pool in
that movie gives us something to just
look at with our Jaws on the floor
asking oh my God how could they do this
to a beloved character and thankfully
we've redeemed ourselves from that it
gave it so much that we had to come back
from The Wolverine made life harder for
everyone coy so I'm not going to lie
those are my first two
choices uh so I'm going to go with the
more standard choice cuz I feel like I
know it well enough and say that episode
one not only hurt Star Wars irreparably
but it actually hurt the people that
watched it because up until episode one
there was hope A New Hope if you will
and that going into that movie people
were broken people watched those credits
rolled and reimagine their childhood
much like we discussed with Robert dairo
when you see a bad performance you go
man did I actually love that I feel like
episode one was so bad that you looked
back on your like the 70s era Star Wars
like were those was I just too young did
I am I a bad movie goer episode one
rewrote Star Wars history with metac
cloran it reestablished Anakin as a
[__] it made you question everything
you loved about the AA try and it was
boring somehow they made a movie about
Star Wars with a 20-minute padr sequence
that was boring that somehow introduced
a senate and Congress and all of these
things that didn't need to be in there
that were boring and they had a lot of
time to make this movie that movie was
written and established and then
happened and there's no excuse in it
being as bad as it was with the amount
of time and hope and potential that we
could have had a real Star Wars Trilogy
especially with the technology that had
led up to that moment there was no
excuse for any of it all right we got
Origins Wolverine Phantom Menace versus
attack of the Clones fight I have did
you see the phantom menace in theaters I
out what did you think of it I I was
really young and even in my youth when
everyone around me had that Collective
I was like oh this is what it's like to
see your Heroes die it was like watching
a rock star be a dick in public where
you're like oh I loved you until you
were the [__] that I always knew you
might be that was not my experience that
was not my experience because I'll tell
you with the phantom menace again you
had Darth Maul I didn't think that the
Pod R when you saw it in the theaters
was as boring as people say it is I
think that so many negative things that
are ascribed to the prequels
particularly episode one came post
episode 2 when the realization set in
that the bad things that were in episode
one that was the rule that wasn't the
exception to it it wasn't that we're
going to get to this new stage in the
story and it's going to get better Liam
n is really good in episode one Darth
Maul is really good in episode one The
Obi-Wan Liam n Darth Maul lightsaber
fight is really good The Duel of the
Fates the John Williams score is really
good there are some great things in
episode one I think there are zero great
things in episode 2 it ruined Boba Fett
it ruined Stormtroopers it ruined Darth
Vader it ruined so many things and it
ruined episode 3 because it completely
handicapped everything that was going to
happen in the next movie as far as X-Men
Origins Wolverine I mean you know as
Andy would say about this last one these
are all bad movies so I you know I can't
say it's a good movie I liked LEF
shriber in it I thought he was good as
Sabertooth I thought that there was some
competent action in that movie and
regardless of what's surrounding him
Hugh Jackman as Wolverine is always
solid and he he's he's G he's doing his
best and he puts in a good great
Wolverine performance he's great as the
character it's just so much there a lot
of solid acting um in the uh in the
Clone Wars uh
attack of the Clon sorry um and uh it
seems like you two are going back and
forth can you be more specific who who
and attack of the Clones would you say
was ex besides you and McGregor oh I was
just going to say you and McGregor okay
okay um and Samuel Jackson and I would
argue the action I would also argue the
action in Attack the Clones is superior
except for the one
fight there's one good fight in episode
one yeah there's one good fight in
episode one there are many good battles
in episode two let me make a major point
I'd love to make a major Point here one
reason why we look at these movies the
prequels those three episodes one
through uh three uh movies like we do is
because we inherently compare them to
the original Three movies yes that that
taints us because uh Andy you know this
we all know this there are just hordes
of young people who hold these movies
the prequels aoft as their Star Wars
films the films that they grew up on and
they don't understand all the noise that
us haters who love the early movies are
squawking about and they even this is
sacrilege but say the early Star Wars
movies are too slow and these so yeah I
don't agree with that but there are
people who love them but we fall victim
of comparing them this movie it killed
Gambit okay it had will I am in it it
had it killed Deadpool for so long there
are people that love this movie because
they compare it to the original H
Jackman Wolverine there are people that
enjoy Wolverine performance in that and
I also think that that movie is a victim
of the writer strike there's no excuse
for Star Wars being what it was thank
you for for that for that great point
this movie is a victim of the writer
strike that makes it worse that makes it
a worse movie yes no one was writing it
yeah it's terrible but these movies had
a lot of time no this movie
yes you're saying like having no wrer
like at least that's a copout that's a
cop out that you can give to this movie
right it gets an out it gets a little no
the movie because it didn't have any
writers that's why garage if you're
going to talk what's the worst of the
worst you got to get down to the and at
least your well it doesn't have writers
and ours had writers that work for
decades decades on these I don't your
argument doesn't compute no writers
equal bad movie period it's what's the
worst movie your argument doesn't make
sense your argument doesn't make sense
your argum bad movie so you're just
repeating that my argument doesn't make
sense instead of actually explaining why
my argument doesn't sense okay I'll
explain it again you um you're saying
the movie had no writers that makes for
a [__] film it's what's the worst
prequel so thank
I'm saying it strengthens our argument
because when we look at ours we're
saying these movies were so terrible and
to add to that they had Decades of work
put into them and they were still
garbage course you can at least say like
well they did the best they could they
didn't have any writers they just they
these movies had every bit of potential
they had every bit everyone wanted to
work on Star Wars who wanted to work on
that movie clearly will I am and that's
it these people wanted a delight why
does everyone talk so much garbage about
will not a delight he mean he had had a
nice made some good he's made some good
music he doesn't belong live shriber
Sabertooth that opening credits with
them was amazing that opening is a
better sequence than anything one of in
episode one better than the Darth Maul
lightsaber fight that was four minutes
of them like dancing around all seeing
lightsabers no I toally it is memorable
because it is a highlight of a [__] film
it is a glorious moment that your feces
drains from your mouth for a second you
go oh this could have been Star Wars
that movie doesn't exist all I've heard
enough
Joe well uh we're talking prequels so
Twitter's got a lot of opinions um uh
Tom Z Beno says how about minions which
I Echo guys minions you could have just
shouted minions over and over again
fight if I'm going to be honest I fought
Wolverine and minions before so I just
wanted something new something fresh I I
had to I had to really dig deep on this
ham pulled dumb and dummer and soless
Golem as does pan count as a prequel
that
Su The Hobbit counted pan a little more
Jackman theob I could have sworn you
were going to go Hobbit I was kind of
hoping you would I gave it a lot of
thought but I thought what was the worst
one and I went with uh X-Men Origins
wolver anything else Joe uh fox movies
uh issued an urgent SOS to the major
agencies looking for a quick rewrite
person to get the script for Wolverine
Origins into Quick shape during the
rider strike so that was absolutely
impacted uh because of the rider strike
they had to some non-un nobody had to
write it in about 4 days to uh get it
ready in time to shoot uh all right well
it was a very interesting fight very
passionate but both of you fell into a
trap where you really did give Hal it's
a trap a very good point of admitting
that without a no script no writers that
is a completely valid point to admit
that his movie is worse but we said that
we used that as a we said that that's a
copout had writers and was worse I was
seeing if you were going to still fight
me Dan cuz I wasn't but I don't like
that you're still fighting come on I
wasn't done I wasn't done shush just
wanted to piss you off a little bit CU I
knew it
would that
said that said uh I think it came down
to it's not phant of Menace I think they
both sort of got you with a little bit
of too much good and then I think Dan
did point out a lot of good things about
yours so I got to give it to
Dan yeah third call in that round I
literally was like I got one of these oh
oh
NOS if you had minions I think you might
have won I never thought you'd say
Wolverine cuz I just I just penciled you
in for a hobbit as soon as I Hobbit and
then we had would you have gone
Wolverine then fight oh there you go
what could have been all right we'll try
that I speed around Wolverine once and
it was like yeah that movie is no very
very Stellar argu sorry I was trying to
piss you off because I thought it might
because I'm I'm a troll I love that you
bait me and then get on to me for
falling into your trap uh but yeah very
intense uh Joe what the what the poll
say well I've only been here for a year
so I haven't seen a whole lot of things
but this is a crazy looking poll uh 34%
X-Men Origins Wolverine 32% Star Wars
Episode 1 Phantom Menace 34% Star Wars
Episode 2 attack of the real TI really
tight there you go that was a fun fight
all right in honor of Moana which came
out there's a couple adorable Sidekicks
in that movie The Chicken powpow the pig
and what's the chicken's name hii HEI
hey and powpow uh anyway we thought what
let's have some fun what is the best
Disney animal sidekick and sorry who
went first last time uh I I did yes
that's right how you're back to first
okay best Disney animal
sidekick you know what the one I love
the most the one that resonates uh just
in my mind the one who's who I who I
sing who I love to talk like and is the
most fun Sebastian the crab from The
Little Mermaid Sebastian is one of the
most fun characters created by Disney he
was such an integral part to push the
story along um such a great friend and
uh had so many key plot points for The
Little Mermaid Sebastian the crab uh is
let's just hear our options and we'll do
a bigger fight Co what's your pick uh my
pick is the only character that is
actually a sidekick and assists the
character in fighting and story mus we
heard the third that's true Mushu Mushu
from Milan Mushu from Milan okay Eddie
Murphy yes Eddie Murphy okay you get a
quick quick State opening statement oh
uh the character not only fights it is
an emotional support a physical support
a storyline support and is a very fun
character because it's Eddie Murphy when
Eddie Murphy was killing it Dan I'm
going all the way back which means I'm
going to lose the Twitter
poll I'm going with the Jiminy Cricket
from Pinocchio oh okay now Dan opening
argument and then you guys can all break
in I'm first yeah just well yeah give me
a quick one yeah I no I think that uh
when I was a kid one of the very first
movies I saw of course I saw Little
Mermaid was was Pino and why I always
loved Jiminy Cricket was he wasn't just
comic relief and he wasn't just there to
kind of help uh you know just distract
to be just something extra to this as a
side character he was Pinocchio's guide
and I like this thing of like he wasn't
just the cute little thing hopping
around behind him like he was literally
his conscience and he tried to help he
tried to push him he also as you're
saying with Mushu he was very integral
to Pinocchio's success in that story he
helped guide him to this journey he
wanted to make him a better person and
that's what I love about a sidekick is
like it's not just somebody who's there
it's somebody who is wants to help and
who actually does help that character
become a better person or puppet as the
case is with Pinocchio and I don't know
he's got When You Wish Upon a Star which
became Disney's like big that's their
song now and I think that that all of
the other animal Sidekicks owe a lot to
Jiminy Cricket because he kind of
established what an ideal sidekick was
which is like not just a cute little
thing that's with the main character but
a guide a confidant and and really just
somebody that can help and assist the
main character and when you talk about
that I I think Sebastian the crab uh
along for the ride with the little
mermaid uh uh really helped her in her
Evolution as this young girl who's so
confused and uh and is torn between
being under the sea or going up to the
land he was a trusted friend and a
confidant Jiminy Cricket yeah of course
he's classic he was like the first one
but I think he falls victim to hey the
more you do it the more interesting and
uh and complicated you can make these
characters the more fun you can have
with these characters I think Disney has
done him better has done one better uh
and has one uped him several times since
and uh you mentioned Eddie Murphy was
killing it I don't know what you're
talking about cuz uh Mulan was uh in the
'90s Eddie Murphy was killing it in the
80s reminded us how much l Eddie Murphy
it was it was the Norbit arrows about to
come so it was Eddie killing it in in
the movie not in the time I mean I guess
in his family friendly Zone maybe but
he's better as a sidekick as donkey you
know that's a better sidekick I think
Mushu donkey no I think mush donkey
better sidekick much like rock much like
Robin in Batman where he becomes
Nightwing I think Mushu is a character
that is so great as a sidekick you
remember Mulan for Mushu much like I
said Robin this is a character who is
not only a dragon which is the best
animal ever but also this is an animal
who protects Mulan while she's training
and protects identity this is a
character who fights alongside Mulan
with the fireworks this is a character
who's an emotional support for Mulan
this is everything a sidekick needs to
be is spiritual emotional physical and
action based and I feel like I'm not
going to be helped by a cricket in a
fight I'm not going to be helped by a
crab this is a dragon as a sidekick and
he's a great guy that's everything I
want I remember Mulan for the strong
female protagonist but that's just me uh
and um Sebastian um he's got clearly Koy
didn't that was said he just said I
remember mus F flexing action shot I
sound like he disrespected our veterans
ladies I respect a strong woman if is
what I'm trying to say okay and um my uh
my character best Disney sidekick uh
when you think about Disney you think
about the songs he mentioned uh When You
Wish uh which is great but um under the
sea and kiss the girl oh my God I can't
think of a character that has two
especially a sidekick that just I could
sing both of those for you right now
Andy do you want me to just kiss the
goat all right I love I actually love
all three of these Sidekicks but why can
we have some real talk about Sebastian
real quick sure I want to hear why the
other two why are the other ones not
good uh here's the thing about Sebastian
he's got a delight he's got a couple of
delightful songs oh yeah he does and the
Little Mermaid but uh Sebastian was a
narc Sebastian ratted Ariel out to King
Triton at every chance he told her the
king where her little Trove of of human
Treasures was and he destroyed it and
basically the only reason Sebastian was
with Ariel the whole time was because he
was talking to King trit and he was like
teenagers suck and King TR is like yeah
they do you know what why don't you go
hang out with my daughter all the time
and keep an eye on her and he was like
oh [__] now I have to go do this he
didn't even want to hang out with Ariel
he was there under duress you know what
so Ariel needed someone to watch her
back besides uh you you
know is he was he under duress what was
Sebastian under duress
uh what do you mean was he under duress
he was
in he want to be there yes he wanted to
be with Ariel he was friends with Ariel
but then why he R her out all the time
he was he was more of a sidekick to the
king because that was where King's
composer he worked for the king that was
the Loyalty was with the King and your
reply to that over that it's a good
point yeah of course he was like he was
like a nanny for Ariel he was watching
her but at the end of the day he was
Ariel's like one of closest friends and
confidants you know because his dad told
him to be I don't know well I mean how
you wind up there is how you wind up
there mush Mushu I think is uh a very
funny sidekick and and I I agree that
Eddie Murphy was this was a reminder of
like oh Eddie Murphy did a great voice
it was pre- Shrek it was great it was a
great character he's cute but I think
that uh I think Mulan could be Mulan
without Mushu I think Mushu is a very
cute sidekick and he added a lot of
humor and comedy to that film but I I
don't think he was instrumental in h and
having Mulan be the person that she is
he may have helped in the fight but
Mulan was a great strong character and I
think she could have found her way
without Mushu I think that when we're
talking Sidekicks I think jimy Cricket
is the best because he helps Pinocchio
achieve his goals he helps him achieve
his dreams and he helps him become the
person that he wants to be can I say one
thing can first go ahead okay I think
that when I want a sidekick I want
someone that isn't just a conscience and
I want someone that isn't just a nanny I
would rather have my sidekick have more
versatility than just being a positive
because I'd like my sidekick to be along
for the ride with me and give me
opinions that are both good and bad so I
make my own decisions and that's why I
value Mushu over jimy Cricket because he
was independent of his own decisions and
he helped in so many different facets
than just being a force of positivity
because if if I wanted that I would just
rely on my conscience and I feel like
with I I just never felt like I trusted
Sebastian and I always felt like he was
like kind of a weird sketchy side
version of a character that I wouldn't
really rely on and therefore that's much
like it's the opposite so conscience and
demon on your shoulder like those are
two things I don't want Mushu was his
Zone man and he was a
Dragon Z man okay um I hey I hate to say
it but Jiminy cricet is a punk ass
[__] yeah I said it okay all the all
the all the [__] that we're
talking about okay flying solo Jiminy
Cricket needs the help of the magic of
Tinkerbell he can't even pull it off by
himself first of all Tinkerbell's in
Peter
Pan
what do you guys need me to if you're
referring to the blue fairy the Blue
Fairy TIG just wanders into the wrong
movie like oh [__] there was a fairy yes
Blue Fairy okay I'll allow it all right
thank
you um and uh and and Mushu listen I I
went to peing Garden the other night had
some bad Mushu chicken that gave me
diarrhea okay the worst I don't think
Mushu is responsible for your diarrhea
I'm going to count out Mushu but uh all
right how you're out of this
one
you were I'm I've heard
enough I appreciate the effort but I
think they uh they nked you out on that
one and uh as much as Sebastian is one
of my favorite characters he really is
kind of a jerk I saw a version where
where Tinker Bell was there Peter Pan
was there Pinocchio was there
b was there uh so we came down to Mushu
and jimy Cricket so I was very closely
um I liked your argument that he didn't
need uh Dan that Mulan doesn't need
Mushu uh but then I really liked Coy's
argument about the conscience uh and you
know um or an Annie Minds its own person
and versatile and gets it it's it's sort
of own
thing I I I I don't love Mushu that much
but I get what you were saying and I
think it's a valid point it's he offers
a little bit more than just the
conscience and is also in a way the
conscience so good fight there koi Ko's
on the board
yes all right jimy Cricket is a punk
ass that might make a moment that might
have been one of a moment for the next
round wow what a great sh I never
thought I would hear that sentence in my
life we're making moments here on this
episode all right here we go number five
this is an epic one this is a lot of fun
um uh here we go what uh here we go uh
worst comic book movie
there's a lot to pick from this is an
epic question we've never actually done
this I was surprised wow what is the
worst comic book movie who do we start
with I think coy coy so I let can we
just get your movies out first I think
we started start with so now it's Coy's
turn Okay so no inro just mov just tell
me your
movie oh I I want to know how we're all
going to fight this yeah it's a great
section uh 2015's Fantastic 4 okay we
got Fantastic 4 Dan that's a good one
this might be a controversial Choice
tell me if this counts if if there's if
there's too much can I I would like to
say Dragon Ball Evolution that's manga
is that a does that does that count or
no Joe I mean if you count Japanese
culture and literature as comic books
are we supped to if you want me to not I
can go with something else I don't know
just asking we can stay in traditional
Comics if you want I I'd give it I don't
want there to be controversy here but a
comic came to my mind consider a manga a
comic book it's just backward comic book
I don't do you want to win on a
technicality I fine I I'll go with the
more I'll go with the more conventional
Choice fine I will say Superman 4 the
Quest for piece okay just a movie no one
scen we're like yeah Dragon Ball
Evolution Halle Berry's Catwoman okay
fantastic for Catwoman and Superman
Quest for Peace okay wait JT there's a
typo on there what there's a typo can
you fix
that what is the best comic book movie
we are introducing a new new segment
called the trick question no that's not
a trick question that's a lie that's
just betrayal that's a betrayal is what
that is good job thinking for nothing
nerds that's what that question is oh so
here we go this is now a new format we
just came up with that I'm very excited
about called the trick question now that
you've all played your cards and told me
the worst comic book movie You Must
defend it as the best now oh Mother of
God oh wait no so we have to take our
answers and movie this would have been a
great round to be
contrarian oh so now you must defend
your comic book movie this is a three
Fighters awesome Fighters you got to
prove your worth here okay tell me why
yours now is the best Dan why is
Superman 4 the Quest for me the best Coy
why is Fantastic 4 the best and how why
is Catwoman the best now I will give you
one bit of advice before this fight
starts if you give in and give me bad
qualities about your film that's thrown
in the towel and I will consider that
failure you love this movie we clear
okay all in fact all three of these are
great movies right in some regard just
like you've been treating the Scorsese
fight treat this like it's the Scorsese
fight all right here we go best comic
book movie koi why is Fantastic 4 the
best comic book movie
2015's Fantastic 4 fixed everything they
did wrong in the original two Fantastic
Fours Fox tried to make they finally
listened to the fans and they gave us a
sue storm we cared about they gave us a
Mr Fantastic that uses powers in
creative ways they gave us a thing that
actually said it's clobber in time that
really you felt for and you were
invested in they gave us an amazing
Human Torch in Michael B Jordan that Not
only was charismatic and charming and
you felt like could actually do the
action but he was in endearing he was
Johnny Storm every time Johnny Storm was
on screen that's a person you wanted to
follow you wanted to be friends with you
wanted to have a beer with Mr Fantastic
seemed intelligent seemed like he could
actually get his way through things and
it gave us a doctor storm that we'd
never seen before it gave us action
unlike anything we ever have and it gave
us deep cut comic references with the
Negative Zone and with the Fantastic car
being referenced it gave us so many
things we never thought we'd seen and it
almost gave us hope for Fox having a
credible Fantastic Four to go along with
their X-Men and giving us a challenge to
Marvel it was so good it gave us
potential to have a rival to Marvel
Cinematic Universe in Fox's Fantastic 4
that could team up with the X-Men and it
was set in a universe that felt like the
X-Men could be involved and it was
brilliant wow damn counter arguments I
assumer later let's see open Super four
the Quest for Peace first of all is
there any more American just not even
American he's a citizen of the world
hero than Superman he is an icon of Hope
and the name of the movie is Superman 4
the Quest for Peace and how many of
these what do we give all of these
superhero movies so much crap for these
days they're dark and depressing and
it's all about fighting and verses and
how much everybody's at each other's
throats this is a story about Superman
trying to achieve world peace this is a
story about Superman on behalf of
humanity saying as a citizen of the
world I am going to take steps to ensure
that you will not be able to destroy it
that you will have to work your
conflicts as human beings as as citizens
of the earth and he's standing up
against someone who's literally himself
that Lex Luther is manufacturing as the
opposite of him and at the end of this
movie he still stands tall and the World
by the way is has no nuclear weapons is
a world at peace Superman brings peace
to the world what is a bigger superhero
action than bringing peace to the planet
Earth how Catwoman why is it the best
Catwoman is the best superhero film of
all time hi Berry coming off an Academy
Award for Monsters ball wow I mean in a
towering performance a complete change
of pace we saw one speed in Monster's
Ball make me feel good and then she she
drove a super hero genre film like no
woman save no actor has ever done before
and have we ever met a more diabolical
villain than Sharon Stone oh when when
she stepped on the screen I mean before
I mean it brings to mind I wonder if
Heath Ledger watched Sharon Stone to
prepare for his Joker later in the dark
night it was directed by a Frenchman and
you you can see um the influence of
French
Cinema his his name he goes by one name
it's PTO P it was directed by POF and
PTO is a student of Gard he's a student
of the French new wave and you could see
that he crafted a cinematic gem like the
likes of which we'd never seen I could
keep going about Catwoman she is a
tertiary character in Batman's Rogues
Gallery but she is turned into a
beautiful
anti-hero by Hal Berry so not only like
you guys are like talking about uh stuff
we've seen before from Superman this
changes the game changes the game gives
us a side a Catwoman that we had yet to
see all right guys fight it out not only
isn't halberry the best superhero she's
not the best Catwoman I would put her
behind Michelle fer Lee Maryweather
Julie numar Eartha kit whoever voiced
Catwoman in the Batman animated series I
call them my girlfriend has a cat named
muffin who if you put a mask on would be
a better Catwoman than H Berry was I'm
not saying neither of your movies are
memorable but my movie is Far and Away
the most memorable of these films this
movie has so much heart to you're like
man after Chronicle it makes sense for
Josh Tran to go to Fantastic 4 I'm glad
he already established how good he was
at directing action and superheroes that
he was ready to establish an entirely
new franchise in the fox Universe
Superman didn't do anything he in the
first
Superman cured Humanity you'll believe a
man can fly was the catchline of the
first film by the fourth film we no
longer believed he could fly cuz he
barely flew in that he flew into space
fought in space he carried the Statue of
Liberty in midair how what more heroic
thing literally FW in the air with the
stat believe 30 years or 10 years after
the first film I no longer believed in
the CGI that should have been more
advanced that I didn't believe a man
could fly both of your films are [__]
garbage okay Superman Quest for peace
the worst special effects maybe of any
film of all time and when it's a big
when it when it's a superhero film
that's problematic that that one of the
worst villains of all time those claws
laughable so much wrong so phoned in so
poorly done um it breaks my heart that
that was Christopher Reeves last
Superman and um with fantastic for oh
man Josh Tran had a vision they wouldn't
let it do it and ending of that movie
it's like show up we got one green
screen day we'll shoot the ending
garbage the only one of these movies
that has a sequel in production is mine
that is not true there is no sequel
fantastic in prodction happening as far
they haven't erased it off the
chalkboard at Fox yet was never a and
there was never a chalkboard for a
sequel to
Superman now mine is the one that
clearly was the best because it has a
sequence first of how can't attack my
character so he attacks my film's budget
that is not fair and I will say this
about both of our movies it has no
basketball scene as your movie does how
one of the worst
scenes for bringing that
Catwoman we showed a whole other side it
was you know what um okay I'm going to
say this right now it's better than Teen
Wolf as far as basketball surpr oh it's
beautiful isy there is no better
basketball scene in any film sport or
otherwise than Teen Wolf's basketball
scene except Hal Berry as Catwoman d d
I wish the Harlem gold CHS had been in
that Scene It would have made it
possibly bearable your movie if I was
going to pick a movie that was
everything wrong with superhero movies
it's fantastic 4 oh my God family
casting against typ so we can actually
have an interracial family changing the
dynamic of the team to make it more I
care about the casting I wanted to go
sit in a dark room alone for 6 hours
after that movie was over it was movie
was so ahead of its time it recast a
character established this white with
the better African ameran choice because
he was Johnny
Storm it gave us a young Miles Teller as
Mr Fantastic because it would have been
easier to cast a Mr Fantastic that was
the more standard issue
symp the thing dropping out of that air
the airplane to fight was like such an
in that wasn't even the movie that was
in the trailers that was not in your
movie not it was cut out of the movie it
was only in the trailer the thing I've
always wanted I'm shocked and saddened
that neither of you gentlemen have
mentioned the beautiful heart and soul
of
Catwoman oh I'm about to tell you I'm
about to tell you Hal Berry is a graphic
designer for an evil Cosmetics company
and she comes across their horrific plan
and hi Barry it's a strong statement for
women empowering each other I'm talking
about the entire story of the film it's
a story about women empowering
themselves and not being beholden to the
beauty industry and certain standards of
beauty what is Catwoman's name in that
movie what is oh Hal Berry's character's
name that escapes me at the moment but I
love it and that's how meable that film
is that's how memorable that film is now
my character has a strong female lead
and my film has a s storm that is
credible likable and keeps up with Reed
Richards it shows an entire family of
characters better than your character
that doesn't even have a name your film
is a fourth film in a series where we'd
already giv up in everyone M starts an
entire film is about hope it is about
brightness it is about Superman saving
the world which he does at the end is
about standing up to the evils of
nuclear power not nuclear power but
nuclear uh uh bombs which was an
enormous massive thing still in the
1980s when the Cold War was still going
on he brought peace to the Earth
something no other superhero has been
able to do Hal Berry's character is
named patience there you go my film is
about a family who bonds together and it
shows us what it means to be a
superpowered family in a way unlike I
mean I'd say more The Incredibles did
fil are ridiculous claims that film was
flashed out I stand by every claim I
make about Superman 4 the Quest for
final thoughts Dan these guys are both
saying like well you know they do this
they do this I'm saying this is what's
the best superhero movie ever what is a
superhero in essence about superhero is
about peace and hope and humanity and
being a beacon of light and that is what
Superman is and Superman for the Quest
for Peace he takes on his greatest enemy
he defeats him and he leaves the world a
better place
Catwoman doesn't leave the world a
better place yes she does the Fantastic
Four like half the world gets ripped up
into whatever trash hole Circle that was
in the third act I don't even know what
that was at the end of Superman 4
Superman Glides across the face of the
planet Earth and looks down at the peace
that he has given the world I can't
think of a greater superhero deed than
what he accomplishes in that movie how I
imagine pet a young boy growing up on
the south of
France saying I want to give something
to humanity and he did it's called
Catwoman it's a story that empowers
women it takes this character who's only
a side dish so many movies and TV shows
and makes her the entree hi Berry a
beautiful followup to her Oscar winning
performance I'm surprised she didn't go
Tom Hanks and go back to back and Sharon
Stone an epic villain this the story has
a soul and a heart Dan um yours is the
worst of the four Superman movies and
it's laughable yours is a big mistake
that movie um Josh trying to tried to do
something they took it away from him and
then tacked on an ending ending up with
a a dumpster fire Coy last thoughts now
the question isn't who's the best
superhero because you described what
makes a good superhero the question
isn't who has the most Oscars the
question is what is the best superhero
movie what do you go into a superhero
movie for you go in to have Easter eggs
that reference Comics references you
don't think you'll see you go in for
Action you go in for character
development you go in for family this
movie has action set pieces out the
Wazoo this movie has the characters
doing stuff we haven't seen them doing
anything but the comics this movie has
entire setb set in the negative Zone a
thing that up until 2015 we never
thought we'd get to see this movie has
Dr Doom this movie has everything you
want in a cinematic Masterpiece and a
comic book movie needs those things
neither of viers had them I don't care
about the alings I don't care about
Superman this movie was listen superhero
film and it is the best of
them oh man that was intense Jo what are
they saying on the
boards so uh I mean according to Twitter
here uh for one they love the trick
question that that blew a lot
of uh but according to Twitter Howen
Howen Dan brought knives to a koi
gunfight uh just a few things to cover
here uh Catwoman's name in this movie is
patience Phillips did pulled it yeah um
this is pof's only
feature uh he is the special he is the
visual effect uh director for such films
as alien resurrection and um that's
about it and
delices uh Fantastic 4 uh 2 is off the
release calendar uh they they did pull
that Box Office Mojo was the first
company to report that that is no longer
on any
whiteboards who based on the arguments
uh uh man this is really tough how you
had some serious passion there I I mean
High marks the whole way and it's not I
I'm still deciding it's in my head cuz I
think if I got to pick one on passion
you got you got it
there but then Koy you did you did make
a good point that Dan's really talking
about the hero more than the movie which
is a Val valid valid counter argument to
him because he is oh he leaves it's all
about peace but not really about the
movie more about the character trait so
that's what the movie's about that was a
good knock there uh so it really it does
come down to Hal and koyi uh Dan you're
already in so it doesn't even matter uh
but between how and Koy and based on
those arguments do I there was some
passion coming from Koi too action we
got to see the Negative Zone you made a
good point uh uh the interracial family
Dr suit storm how it fixed everything
you got the clobbering line in uh
diabolical Sharon Stone on the other
hand could have could have motivated
Heath
Ledger oh my God I mean best ever and
and your you're just the the thought
process of p uh and his French New Wave
style shared X-Men
Universe all the action set pieces oh
man this is rough do I go for the funny
or do I go for the better argument Joe
what do you think I mean sometimes
question in this instance it's kind of
hard cuz it's a trick question yeah I
mean you know if any word that sums up
this round it's wolf but I've got to go
I've got to go over style here I got to
go koi yeah I got to give props though
to how and you almost won me over just
on the your because it is a creativity
and I I it's more of a creative comedy
choices there but I got to give koi
substance a little bit more uh so Koy
gets the
points that was the hardest fight of my
entire movie fight Round of Applause for
now I wish I could take you the end just
for that compassion
there I did also see to look up the
names oh I knew
it if you hadn't done that I might have
swayed me uh so coy uh that's it you
made it the uhoh yeah look at this tied
up too the fans have been wanting this
speed round the champ Merl going up
against Koy this the Micro Machines man
he's got the advantage here I think stay
tuned after the speed for some fun uh
facts on some upcoming fights but here
we go uh you guys know how this works
let's get straight to it it's a long
episode I don't need to explain how the
speed round Works uh I will need you to
help time it do you have a do we have
another Bell for Joe over there to help
uh Joe you ready on the counter I'm
ready here these are these are tough
ones we did not uh skimp Andy we're 20
and 10 okay 20 and 10 20 seconds 10
seconds yes 20 and 10 uh yes uh oh Bas
did we get a poll on that last question
uh we did let me bring it up curious
what was the best uh fan forti won it
okay didn't run away with it Superman uh
Quest for Peace was pretty close
followed by H Berry's magnumopus trick
question we'll talk I'm in love with
that we'll be doing that again someday
we'll talk about after the fight all
right here we go uh here we go round one
is a Bargain Bin I don't know who
submitted it we'll find out second but
I'm going to show you two uh movies and
you have to tell us which one should we
buy let's hold on let's make this a
Black Friday themed it's it's on sale on
Black Friday okay okay and they're both
the same price which one but I can only
afford one uh which one should I buy all
right here we go
Resurgence Independence Day I'll take
Alice said such
disdain okay we got Resurgence versus
Looking
Glass all right and uh Dan you spoke
first that means you'll begin and the
time will start when you begin
speaking Independence Day Resurgence is
a flawed movie but is still a followup
to a much Beloved movie and I will say
that for everything that's not good
about Independence Day Resurgence there
are things to love it widens the scope
of the alien it has a bigger alien
presence you still like Jeff Goldblum
he's still a fun character you still
have characters that you enjoy in this
movie Al through the Looking Glass is a
retread of a movie that was already
terrible that was 20 wow that goes fast
all right
COI Alice Through the Looking Glass is a
visual Masterpiece of experiencing a
movie that is only based on visuals it
didn't have to be as intelligent as
independent sturgeons was because
independent surgeons is a sequel to a
great film Alison Wonderland was exactly
what it was meant to be which is a
visual thing explaining a movie that is
all about a drug trip and that's what
the movie was it didn't betray the first
one because the first one didn't have a
lot to go on this movie is what it was
meant to be 10 seconds Dan the problem
is that the visuals that they're working
on are garbage it looks like you ran uh
Wonderland through the mud it's awful
it's unpleasant to look at the first one
was this one was Independence Day
there's still some fun to be had 10
seconds when you begin speaking
qu Independence Day 2 is so bad it makes
you doubt the first one's presidential
speech one of the best speeches of all
time it is so bad it knocks down the
first a peg Alice Wonderland is just a c
minus which is what the first one was
and that had no bar to be set inde
dependent say who hurts the first woo
how coming to you man now you have to
help decide this based on arguments this
was an easy one for me I felt like Dan
um just had so many um positive points
about his movie and uh KY uh hung his
argument on the visual style and it's
like if I'm going to buy it do I want to
buy that maybe if I want to like you
know take a like get high or something
to watch but say yeah Dan uh Joe are you
with us yeah you know the one big
argument was the visual style and Dan
through that haduken of the visuals were
awful haduken H great all right Dan you
get the first point here we go number
two best movie facial
hair best facial hair
ooh lon's been pushing for this one for
a while I bet well he would Tony Stark
oo okay best movie facial hair
there so many places to go uh I'm going
to go with
uh oh wow uh let's go with Hans Gruber
and die hard o did you have one H did
you want to make a joke oh no I was
going to say it should have been
sponsored by
movember okay sorry I asked I love you
though uh all right Coy you got have
Tony Stark first uh you have 20
seconds Tony Stark's facial hair is so
good it explains everything he is as a
person it is quaffed it is manicured it
is beautiful it's a reference to the
comics it shows how manicured and
focused he is it shows that he is
arrogant it shows that he is charismatic
it shows everything you need to know
visually about a character that didn't
need that but it also references a comic
which makes fans happy it makes new
viewers happy it makes everyone watching
The Experience happy because it explains
so much while doing so little
Dan
Hans gruber's beard is the optimum
length of any movie beard ever it is not
short enough to be stubble as if you're
some kind of a European gangster it is
not long enough to look like he doesn't
have his sorts it is the exact right
length it is the beard of a man who
knows what he's doing guy fer Smashmouth
I've seen a lot of people with that Tony
starred facial hair Hans grber has the
best beard in any movie ever all right
Co follow
up when I look at Hans G's facial air it
does doesn't tell me who he is as a
person when I look at Tony Starks I know
when I'm invested in a character the
level I need to be at Tony Stark or Hans
grber I need something that is manicured
and fit and perfect and I don't feel H
was it feels lazy damn when I look at
Tony Stark's beard I think singer of a n
late 90s terrible alt Rock Band When I
look at Hans gruber's beard I think
European I think Suave and
sophisticated sounds okay that's tough
Joe a facial hair man fellow fellow
facial hair man so look uh I think that
that was that was the koi people of been
uh wanting to come out shooting he
wasn't there in round one but he sure
showed up in round two but but speed be
damned that guy Fier oh that was that
guy Fier Smashmouth counter I'm giving
this to Dan he's an Allstar wow I still
got to go with Coy I thought uh you're
not going to go to meet no I'm I'm just
saying first then you're you can help be
the tiebreaker H Jesus I I gota say Coy
that was a funny joke but I still think
Coy got more in uh T what are you what
are you saying
Dan's first round argument was so bad it
was amazing it was great comedy just
saying it that's a well groomed
beard um koi had an onslaught and I'm
not saying I completely agree with it
but he passionate and he backed it up
and how the uh Tony Stark's facial hair
related to the comics it um defined and
explained some of the character koi won
it easy for me all right Co gets the
next Point okay that is Imagine Hans
grber without that beard that's all I'm
saying oh I Sam Elliot's mustache big
yeah all right here we
go now for the rest of your life you
could only watch one of these actors
movies you could only watch their
filmography for the rest of your life
who would you pick MH keano Reeves or
Matt
Damon ke
Reeves all right you got Matt Damon coyi
he's thinking he's like all right what
does that mean y Keanu we thought about
this we had a fight in the office uh try
to make sure this was fair wow wow wow
all right uh so Dan you're first Kiana
Reeves why would you pick his
filmography for the rest of your life if
I'm watching a movies a characters an
actor's movies for the rest of my life
I'm going to go with the guy that
brought me speed the guy that brought me
Point Break the guy that brought me the
Matrix the guy that brought me Bill and
Ted's Excellent Adventure I'm going to
go with the guy that entertains me that
provides me with a consistently exciting
filmography from Bill and Ted to John
Wick Keanu has been bringing
it all right COI time starts when you
begin
speaking when I watch a film I want to
be invested in the character more than
just the action I feel like K is a great
actor but he just does Action really
well Matt Damon's goodwi hunting Matt
Damon's uh Talented Mr Ripley Matt Damon
brings such Nuance I could ReDiscover
stuff each time I watch it and I have
all the oceans films if I want to just
have an action film I have so many more
layers with that name than I could get
with yo re that I can rewatch everything
and find new elements each time whereas
C re I get a very specific
note uh okay Dan Matt Davon is tortured
Goodwill Hunting Talented Mr Ripley All
the Pretty Horses oh three borns three
oceans movies Keana reev is action it's
excitement it is Thrills it is what I
want to enjoy COI last thought to
counteract all of his torture he also
has as I said the born films the ocean
films those films that are action packs
where you get the Pathos and the action
of Keanu but with more acting
credibility you get everything from can
put
moreo how back to you oh gosh wow based
on the arguments both very good both
very good damn it I don't want to choose
um do you want me to go to Joe first Joe
do you have an OP have an opinion yeah I
I've Loved where Dan was going and the
point he was trying to get to but he he
didn't quite hit it hard enough for me I
got to go with koyi on this one you know
what I'll go with Dan and leave it up to
you Andy cuz they both had excellent
arguments I mean oh and they're both so
different I was listening I was one of
the easiest ways just who could list the
best movies and I feel like you you
actually had a wash there you both did a
good job with that uh but yeah I didn't
hear much more for Dan aside from it's
action it's action which I think he does
have more and because koi was able to
show the range I got to give it to
koi so ky's ahead we got two more
questions or one more yeah unless you
unless you lose this one Dan this could
be it y it's could be it for you it's
all over could be good thing you to put
the belt then huh yeah chicken out
I'm sorry I'm not trying to you out more
trolling Dan sorry no no no Dan's a pro
I mean Dan could crush you right now CU
he's the best here we go he's a veteran
round sorry round four what movie is
most improved by a second
viewing
fub the six cents ooh fight Club versus
six since you're up first koi with Fight
Club time starts when you begin
speaking Fight Club is the same type of
twist of six sense where when you watch
it the second time you get to experience
it differently but it also has more
layers of nuance you get to see those
flashes that Tyler D and they make more
sense you get to see all the little in
intri syntheses of him like hitting the
car and having it be him first you get
to see people watching Tyler dur and
knowing scenario you get to experience
it through different eyes with the
second version of the film that you
wouldn't get in the first film it's not
just one person carrying it's the entire
sporting cast knows something that we
don't know Dan you got a lot of words
out there someone count
them Dan uh time starts and You Begin
speaking they both have twists I think
that fight Club is essentially the same
film on the second viewing you just
happen to know that Tyler Duran is a
second person it's the same interaction
between the characters six sense is a
different film when you know that Bruce
Willis is not physically present in some
scenes scenes play differently
completely differently you see how
intricately that film was put together
to hide that Twist from you fight club
pulls the rug out from under you but six
cents 10 seconds I couldn't disagree
more they have the exact same twist and
all the intricacies are in my film that
are in yours but you have more of a
Supporting Cast that are reacting to it
instead of just the little boy they're
the same twist the same second viewing
but there's more to you experience in
the second viewing 10 seconds Dan Fight
Club telegraphed that twist with all
them I felt like I was fighting myself
six sense completely pulls the wool over
your eyes and it is a completely
different movie when you see it with the
New Perspective the second
time wow I'm going to give him 10 more
seconds coyi 10 seconds
go
there are more subtle hits to mine I
totally agree but they are all more
invested in the twist whereas yours is
just a little little spots this movie
changes the second viewing because you
care about the twist more you're more 10
seconds Dan the events of the movie play
out the same way the second time with
yours the events of the six sense play
out completely differently because the
character's motivations change
completely on a second viewing you read
more into haly josman's character all
right so wanted to make sure I heard
their arguments CU they did repeat
themselves a bit but they gave a little
bit more color so uh Joe B Bas on those
arguments based on those arguments uh
Dan hit us with technicality how the
movie is laid out and K really started
to have to lean into it makes you feel
which is very subjective so I've got
I've got to go with Dan Hal uh yeah uh
Dan had it uh for me uh I'm not saying
uh I like both their choices but uh Dan
uh made it uh the more impactful viewing
experience yeah I'm with it so Dan
you're back in this is it comes down to
this there's a funny funny fifth
question or a good fifth question I'm
going to go with the good one okay we'll
save the funny for later yeah cuz it's
too serious yeah we don't want another
Milk Dud situation no exactly learn my
lesson this one will make you think but
it's very broad all right best movie
whose
title has four
words jeez Louise stylist
forwards
um h
The Godfather Part
Two
[Music]
damn koi is going to take forever yeah I
can't even now that you said that I
literally can't think
of doesn't think as fast as he talks
yeah I got to
process you
know I'm going to go the other way and
this is going to be very interesting
fight Fast and the
Furious that's the fourth the fourth one
the fourth one you're right or is it
called Fast and Furious the fourth one
the fourth one I think it's fast and the
furious right I thought it was called
Fast and Furious I could be wrong
though sorry internet just slowed down
right when I needed it that's how it
works around here the only time slow
down when I was looking up H's name just
Fast and Furious is just Fast and
Furious you one more
shot you could go Too Fast Too Furious
sh don't help
him Fast and Furious sequel versus the
god sequel Tokyo dri
uh I got one can't give it to him
no I you know can I take his two to
Furious I got an argument or is that is
that misleading okay let's not cheat um
it's a little cheating see Joe that's
why you don't send him out there you're
right oh Captain America Civil War okay
there we go
okay Captain America Civil War versus
Godfather Part Two
Dan The Godfather Part Two The Godfather
Part Two is one of the best American or
any other Nation movies ever made it is
a story about family it is a story about
one man's soul and the Redemption of
that Soul the way that it parallels the
story between the fall of Michael
Corleone and the rise of veto Corleone
is so powerful the way that you see the
rise and fall of this family in America
is one of the absolute most incredibly
well structured and paced movies ever
made
koi Captain America Civil War builds up
from 10 films and then lands beautifully
illustrating everything right about
superhero films it is a good action film
it is a good drama it is a good
character study you care about 10 plus
characters in a film and they're all
given beautiful arcs the movie moves at
a beautiful Pace it is rewatchable it's
entertaining it has all the heart of a
very good drama but with the action of a
perfect Super film Dan 10 seconds Civil
War is Reliant completely on having seen
10 other movies and it does not carry
near the emotional weight to The
Godfather Part Two as anybody can watch
The Godfather Part Two and relate to it
it's about
family 10 seconds COI the pacing of The
Godfather Part Two doesn't allow it to
be the entertainment and the
rewatchability of Captain America Civil
War and Civil War is a stronger movie as
a movie because you can enjoy it by
itself as often as you want all right
how um I was thinking The Empire Strikes
Back yeah I was also thinking the wizard
of v y it's good one um
Dan
Joe this one is uh this one is tough
just based on the arguments uh I think
that the uh it's relying on 10 other
movies is a is a strong
one by a little bit I got to go with Dan
yeah I don't think it was that close Dan
gets it it was tough call Tough call I
mean Dan just really C I mean I got to
give koi props though B battle you
godere I came this close to saying
Captain America Civil War the first
thing Dan had to stumble a little bit
and he didn't he was on the top of his
games that's where you got a little
stuck there but Dan you did it wow and
long last it happened oh my God that was
the that was the speed run I think that
everyone that was that was epic you know
what I'm actually glad that I I lost and
got to see you guys uh and very
impressive it to the end as we expected
all right I've been teasing then we'll
give you guys plug watch guys here after
the fight if you're watching live on
plus but for the next few weeks we have
some amazing live shows you will not
want to miss here we tape Thursdays on
screen.com and next week we are doing an
all Star Wars fight Darth harof himself
Christian harof will be here mod Garrett
Dan Casey he wrote a book on Star Wars
these three know they're Star Wars we
are going to be debating we've asked you
for some there are some amazing
questions so Star Wars movie fights next
week the week after that the following
Thursday myself Alicia Malone and Ken
napso are coming back for the drunk
championship
belt we we need to make a belt with a
gold beer cans Andy let me ask you be
epic how many Mike's Hard Lemonade going
to kill that no here's it's going to be
serious because we're going to have a
bartender who's going to give us all the
same drinks make sure we all are
drinking the same amounts uh it's all
going to be very SS amazing it's going
to be very good so the next couple
Thursdays you're in for a big treat can
I show up and just get drunk yeah if you
like
uh you're on for a big treat uh and then
uh I want to Hype something else that
we've been working on we're in the midst
of it but we are prepping a nice uh all
the movie fights 100 we ask so many
people for their favorite moments some
of them might be in this uh you know in
the next patch from this episode but we
are counting down the 50 best movie
fight moments of all time it's been so
fun to look back I know a lot of you ask
what happened what happened at the end
of this month we are going to give you a
special on plus super long breakdown of
all the history of all the best moments
putting them in order ranking them
giving you our behind the scenes in uh
in Insight on them so stay tuned it's
coming soon I'm so excited about Dan you
can vouch it's going to be a lot of fun
it is we we spent way more time than we
should
have ordering these moments and I think
that and if you're a fan of movie fights
you're going to really really enjoy and
I have to thank Jack Shipley and so many
other fans who helped compile a lot of
this for us because we had to go back
and watch all 100 it's it's just the
first 100 uh but there's so many good
moments Hal you're in there quite a few
times oh glad to hear uh but that's so
so much fun stuff to stay tuned so stay
tuned I'm so excited how rnck how rnck
anything else you'd like to oh I had a
blast and you guys were excellent um
yeah you mentioned Star Wars and your
Star Wars battle com up next week today
we had a screen junkie show where
Christian harof Ken napso myself and
Michael bar who's a huge uh some great
Star Wars videos um we determined the
best Star Wars character of all time
it's a great watch SC show on YouTube
and yeah hit me up on Twitter how
Rudnick Coy jandrew anything you'd like
to plug uh you can find me coy jandre C
J D on Instagram and Twitter and I host
Marvel movie news on Tuesdays and Screen
junkies people on Twitter you guys
helped me get here and I appreciate it I
love you guys so much so help me down
appreciate it Dan Merl much respect to
these two gentlemen it was the battle
that I was hoping it would be uh yeah at
Merl Dan on Twitter like how said the
Star Wars show is really fun and uh I'm
going to give our friend Mark andreco a
plug for his book Love Is Love on id.com
and Amazon it's coming up very soon and
and it's I from everything I hear it's
going to be fantastic kind to come back
and announce some big stuff we heard it
pray
oh I just want to give a shout out to
our friend Jason Inman who's uh sending
comic books to troops for the holiday so
um yeah hit up Jason Inman you know him
from the host ofn on send your comic
books uh Joe star on the couch uh I'm
gonna Echo Twitter they love this fight
this was one of my favorites it was just
there was something just basic and fun
and Back to Basics about well done all
three of you guys just basic basic basic
uh I want to thank uh Robert Ebert for
all of his opinions and his weird three
star rating uh find me on Twitter @ joar
s uh thank you Joe and thank you
everybody here and thank you for
watching at home we will see you live
after the fight here on plus otherwise
we'll see you next week have a good one
Star Wars next week bye-bye
byebye thanks to NatureBox for
sponsoring this episode for more
information click the link in the
description and right now you'll save
even more because nature boox is
offering screen junkies fans 50% off
your first order when you go to
naturebox.com/tyler to join us for
future fights or if you prefer to listen
on iTunes click the logo to download an
audio
[Music]
version